I pin a lot of hair tutorials but I'm
not very good at doing my own hair I
[Music]
have very thick wavy hair it's pretty
thick I have a lot of hair it's frizzy
all over kind of poufy it's not too thin
not too thick it's just like right in
the middle
[Music]
two-minute updo tutorials
two minutes looks like he took like all
day put the hair elastic on like a crown
then I like try to look real Coachella
but I'm gonna probably end up looking
like I have a mushroom on my head
there's no like word this is hard and
twist it up then keep tucking your hair
in there's no good for short hair it
doesn't even accept it it's like the
rubberband doesn't even get my hair oh
my god this is a matter I don't think
this looks good like even on the model
that's doing it I mean I think I did it
but I hate it okay if I put if I keep
putting one side then the other one
falls it well here you have it now we're
gonna do it easy hair bow emphasis on
the easy oh god this is the worst I've
got extensions for this this is that's
it doesn't really say what to do it just
has photos you look like a warrior but
the hairs that I got in the fence then
you quickly grab a piece of hair as fast
as you can
I don't know they're not telling me
anything I'm just making educated
guesses but really like I'm nailing it I
have testicles on my head everyone is
really cool like easy throwing up hair
and then I try it and I look like a
demonized Mickey Mouse drayton braid
ways I'm gonna braid my entire head but
this girl only has like four braids in
her hair that I like this big this is
really gonna take people there's nothing
I have so much hair this girl has no
hair at all
la-dee-da gotta braid my hair for a good
20 minutes I've transformed myself into
Snoop Dogg there's just so great right
now I guess I right and then here we go
another 20 we think you could poop at
least 10 times in that in that period
this better look good what's better this
or this Herbal Essence commercial
look at it I look like when Simba got
out of the water it looks frizzy and
weird
Oh Pinterest is so cool hole and I go on
it every day and I just feel like a
little girl whose hopes and dreams are
shattered daily if you have short hair
there's really not not much you can do
unless the person is actually like a
short hair specific Pinterest err maybe
someone that is better at the tennis
stuff would have better luck than I just
have bu you know like pay attention to
these tutorials but like do it the way
you would want to do it